welcome to the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences welcome Natalie only evidence
cops Academy welcome not a ball colony
is AmeriCorps either her faith and
scopes Academy in Samantha Vltava salute
or Moretz noble PC Jimmy now hit the Rio
Rancho on Sunday Academy's stand the
secretary or may may you know oh you're
good for ndon a Nobel Committee and
Fushimi professor Soros new group
Lindsey awk professor Klaus Gustav zone
so may lead amount of Nobel Committee
and Oken of expectant item threesome
rodent
I'm Jordan Hansen secretary-general of
the Academy and with me is the chairman
of the Nobel Committee for chemistry
professor Soros nor Europe Linzer and
also professor Klaus Gustav's on member
of the Nobel Committee I will start by
announcing the price and read the
citation we will hear about the
discoveries and the laureates from our
experts and we hope to have one of the
laureates with us by phone and of course
you ladies and gentlemen of the media or
welcome to ask questions either in
English or in Swedish or its priests
harem Selden's Varrick ship slow the
Ferrari Pereira da no this year's prize
is about the sales toolbox for repairing
DNA kinetoscopes Academy nobis looted at
Hugo and Rafa more Nobel Prize SME
scale Estella's Jimmy and Sant till
tomas lindahl paul modrich or casas
Sonia
for mekinese Disqus division of the nori
parachute the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to award the 2015
Nobel Prize in Chemistry jointly to
tomas lindahl paul modrich and assist
sonia for mechanistic studies of DNA
repair for mechanistic on to Seohyun be
threatened denali para to pune vetted de
la operación de la dia the Isla de Vanya
mechanism of RepA ROTC TN car and now
professor Soros new goreleans edit chair
of the Nobel Committee will give some
introductory remarks surah please
damages occur to your DNA every day in
fact right here right now if all of
those errors were left and corrected
your genetic material would have very
little resemblance to the original
chromosomes in your very first cell life
as we know it today is totally dependent
on DNA repair mechanisms as have been
revealed in molecular detail but this
year's chemistry laureates their
findings have enormous consequences as
just one example they have led to in
size what may go wrong in conditions
such as cancer
this is a simplified model of DNA
it covers 22 base pairs this little
piece in reality is only eight
nanometers long but every cell of you
contains some hundred million times more
DNA which covers the distance of two
meters
it contains the recipes to make all the
proteins needed to build you and make
you function almost every cell of you
have almost exactly the same DNA so
there must be mechanisms to mean
maintain the information if I were to
pull out the DNA from a German body and
place it in one row it will cover the
distance from the earth to the Sun and
back 250 times although it's so much
it's remarkably similar we have a repair
mechanism but we also have a replication
machinery that copies the DNA at each
cell division and this has a remarkable
fidelity still like every chemical
process it makes mistakes at random so
there will be errors but the DNA can
also be damaged by other insults like
radiation or spontaneous decay or
chemicals poisons for example as found
in cigarette smoke all those insults
cause a variety of structural changes to
the DNA molecule
therefore we need multiple repair
pathways as will soon be described by my
colleague class gustav Thank You Sara
close and ready to give us some insights
into this year's prize I'm ready
so this is our DNA or genetic material
and in every single cell in our body we
have genetic material that encodes for
the creation of a human being and this
this information is stored in DNA
is written with a very simple chemical
language containing only four letters or
four bases eighty D&C and changes to
this information or damages to the DNA
can have very serious consequences so
what are those consequences well for
instance DNA damage limitations can
cause cancer and they are also seen as
an important country or important
contributing factors to normal
biological aging how then do these DNA
damages occur but how do we get them
well it turns out that DNA is by to
being the carrier of genetic information
actually has limited chemical stability
our first Nobel Prize laureate attuma's
Lindell demonstrated that there are a
number of spontaneous camp chemical
processes in our cells they take place
all the time
and that breaks down the DNA slowly for
instance just one of these processes
it's what you have here normally in the
DNA you have base pairs between C and G
to different bases but sometimes what
happens is that the C breaks down and
forms a you instead you is base or a
letter that you would normally not found
find in the DNA and there must be some
way to get rid of this tomas lindahl
calculated that we this reaction happens
about 200 times in every living cell
every day so over time we would actually
lose all our C's too much speculated
there must be a repair system and he
went out to search for it and then he
could indeed find one which repair
system that we know know now know as
base excision repair what does this
system can do is that it can recognize
the you in
DNA it can flip it out and take it away
and then the number the set of other
reaction replaced you with a correct C
again this is just one of many types of
base repairs that the base excision
repair system can take care of we now
know we know today that there are more
than hundreds different lesions to DNA
that can be repaired by the base
excision repair system and it caused the
information in our genomes DNA imitation
may also rise during DNA replication
which is the process when the genetic
material is copied and when you need to
copy the DNA well that is when a cell is
going to divide you need to take the
netting information in the first cell
and you need to make two copies that can
go to the two daughter cells and in
order to do this you need to replicate
or copy DNA and what happens then is
that the double-stranded DNA is split
open like this and each of the two
original strands are used as templates
to synthesize new companion strands and
during this process it is extremely
important that we recreate exactly the
same base pairs that were in the
original original DNA molecule like this
one at EA but on very rare occasions one
in a million there is actually an error
introduced there is a base kameen that
shouldn't be there
and we call this incorrect bases
Michener mismatches our second Nobel
Prize laureate Paul mudra she has spent
his life trying to figure out how these
mismatches how they are corrected and he
has found a system which we now know as
the mismatch repair system and this
repair system contains a number of
different proteins and what these
proteins can do is that they can
recognize a mismatch you see this red
blue thing here is supposed to be a
mismatch it can recognize a mismatch and
then it
also recognize which of the two strands
that are newly synthesized because you
were able to correct the strand that's
newly synthesized you don't want to
change the old strand and then you
cleaved a newly synthesized strand and
you take away the piece of DNA
containing the mismatch and then the DNA
is simply synthesized again and we get
the correct strand this is a very
important mechanisms that the mechanism
that that increase the fidelity of the
inner replication with a factor of about
1,000 and it's a very important factor
in in preserving genetic information in
our genomes finally we can also get
damage to our DNA due to external
sources like UV light ultraviolet light
present in ordinary sunlight and one of
the the things that can happen is that
if we have two T's the let the T's here
in the DNA next to each other if we if
we get your ultraviolet light on these
T's sometimes they can actually they can
actually be a chemical linked perform
between them like this that destroys the
structure of DNA this has serious
consequences both for the structure and
function of the DNA and and we cannot
tolerate that our last Nobel Prize
laureate assists an ER has investigated
how one can take away this type of UV
induced damages in DNA and he has
identified the components and
characterized the mechanisms or what we
know now what we now know as nucleotide
excision repair this repair system
recognize these chemically linked T's
and then it Cleaves the DNA on each side
of this you've induced lesion and cuts
away the damaged DNA strand like this
after this we can synthesize a new piece
of DNA which is then chemically correct
this type of nucleotide excision repair
is not only important for you Vindhya
induced the damages but also take away
many other types of damages for example
reduce that are created by a compounds
that that we get in when we smoke
cigarettes together our free Nobel Prize
laureates this year have explained basic
mechanisms basic cellular mechanisms at
the molecular level that help to gourd
integrity of our genomes and for this
the Royal Academy of Sciences Swedish
Academy of Sciences is extremely proud
to present to them the 2015 a year Nobel
Prize in Chemistry Thank You Klaus Craig
Nobel Prize I hope we now may have to we
have too much lindahl with us on the
phone line from London thank you Tom a
motive maybe we should continue in
English out of courtesy to our
international journalists so who would
like to start asking professor Lindahl
in question too much pnina Hey - most
fun heinous is televi cool the plants
can do what you can therefore through
good poo angles Casilla little specular
foon what will help vehicle stunts we
can be so dr. Borlaug acid will have it
live it is looped my god can you result
here I consider all our gold airship to
mild so we will net that don't
coordination occurs on a liter okay the
mostly first Potomac and Eastman force
Cortana
IRA's questions we would like to
continue yes there's a microphone coming
to you does this system work the same
way in ourselves as in the cells of
pathogens and if there is a difference
is there any medication that utilizes
this new DNA repair mechanisms or
universally distributed all living cells
have repaired mechanisms about they are
more or less efficient and we try to
identify weak targets in pathogens but
they are pool at repair DNA and become
perhaps damaged them that selectively
[Music]
it's too early to say that we can target
a specific pathogen this way yeah we
just have to understand that many of the
drugs we use damage DNA and so there is
a balance here we have our own repair
mechanisms to try to counteract the DNA
damage when we want to selectively
damaged cells that cancer cells or
infected cells the repair mechanisms or
less than helpful but without repair
mechanisms we wouldn't be long-lived one
final thing it was mentioned that
cigarette smoke damages DNA do you know
how that happens
yes cigarette smoke contains
if they're small chemicals they bind to
the DNA and prevent the DNA from being
read properly or replicated properly so
the earth mutagen sir
and once the damaged DNA this can result
in the number of diseases including
cancer thank you
do we have more questions just one over
there first okay
[Music]
Academy or you rose with a fedora and
bathroom until a gift for cleaning your
mattress and that for sickening some
very other pathologies instituted who
the boss insulting you see an area so
actually make some every of livid and
they are not audience conceded to the
visitor the portly an international vac
some hints and s.muhammad arbitrary
ibadan receive sorry
tie the horan Fraga shed un Axelson
thank you for giving me the chance and
congratulations to Hamas I'm sufficient
access home from China radio and green
post I just like to ask you that what
was your first reaction when you hear
the news and did you expect these no
surprise I know that over the years I
have occasionally being considered for
the price but so are hundreds of other
people I feel very lucky and proud to be
selected today thank you yeah please I
played from for of Rammstein
something about what led you into this
research why did you think it was a
interesting problem to figure out why
these get converted to use and and back
yes I was studying the properties of DNA
and found somewhat to my surprise that
DNA is much more stable than we usually
recognize it gets damaged in cells by
the Bolivian and that cannot be avoided
so that means you have to repair the DNA
all the time that wasn't known and nor
were the mechanisms know that deals with
is spontaneous DNA damage so we applied
by that and some of those mechanisms are
also used as defense against dangerous
compounds in the environment and drugs
and so on that main purpose is to
provide the defense against unavoidable
DNA damage thank you next question
hello David Keaton from The Associated
Press professor we're here in the words
and we are in the words smoking these
are things that
everyone can understand the impact of
these diseases and how how they can
affect the lives of millions of people
can you tell us a little bit how this
breakthrough in science can lead to
better treatment and and better better
medicine yes as I mentioned it's very
important that we have DNA repair in
unfortunate individuals that have
defective DNA repair they died early or
have serious medical problems so we have
to have the energy apart on the other
hand if we treat the cancer cell with an
anti-cancer drug that often acts by
damaging the DNA of the cancer cell so
we try to kill the cancer cell and the
cancer cell fights back by DNA repair so
we have to address to the sword we need
a DNA repair but we don't like it that
the cancer cells can repair the DNA so
we have to understand the mechanism so
we can selectively provide good
therapists okay so the millions of
people that are going to be hearing
about this prize today what does it
what's the food should it bring to them
[Music]
we can provide better treatment better
drugs because we have to understand how
DNA is damaged we can't avoid DNA damage
we lived in a world where we get exposed
to DNA damaging agents all the time and
many of those all in ourselves and we
can't avoid them thank you
do we have more questions passion
operator has another one that he needs
an answer oh can we get a microphone
I'm sorry for all so many questions but
it's very interesting
I'm thinking about viruses do they have
this mechanism or how are they related
anyway to this research yes
bacteria and large viruses can code for
their own DNA repair mechanisms and that
helps overcome the defense mechanism of
the host that is not always a good thing
for us so we have to understand how the
DNA repair mechanism works and this is
what I and others have been doing yeah
so we can for example by radiation
selectively kill tumor cells without
damaging the individual thank you
do we have yep the lady over there
you'll get the microphone first where
they swore to say icon create member
little masculine a booster am heforshe
sistema something pure of count such
example can survive in Europe selective
that cancer cell affair and cancers
early an abnormal northern no laws that
hopefully will most of the student for
sure are say so RT can enact Avira
cancer Savannah if they're not scored
Adam said you know Matt Hall selectively
gambling area and then the man Roger
active stole named Cal distraught with
therapy would be food from the Arabic
just made alcohol at the Hampton cancer
the Harriet of them here Tom laudanum
console for skinning indeed or at Cana
just for hindrances el dinero para el
océano Felicia yep briefly a frog or
hell how lucky no it does so long to do
Huckabee to muslin doll for otama meals
thank you very much too much for being
with us today
congratulations again to you Nobel Prize
and welcome back to your old hometown in
December
thank you very much and apologize to the
english-speaking people who have to sit
through this Swedish presentation the
problematic thank you very much bye bye
for now
okay let's move on to questions to our
experts on the panel questions from the
media have we exhausted all questions
already or do you have anything you'd
like to bring up ask us about this is
your chance yes please I would like just
like to know if they have collaborated
the three laureates not to my knowledge
they have worked the completely
independent of each other and it's
different mechanisms for DNA repair as
you said yes more questions
okay yes Jonah rose please yes I wonder
there are three different mechanism you
just mentioned are there many more
mechanisms but the research is going on
definitely I mean new DNA repair
mechanisms or being discovered as we
speak probably so there are many other
mechanisms have been discovered in
recent years and one can say that we
gave a big it when we talk about these
prices we talk about the original
discoveries in in in bacterias often but
what has happened is of course that all
these free Nobel laureates they have
continued with their work for many many
years
and their transfer their knowledge into
the alien system so they see that the
same principles apply also in our human
cells and as I said there or there are
definitely other forms repair which are
also very important so this is what this
or these are very early discoveries and
they opened up the field I understand
that make means that this could exist
well when were they made so in the the
first discoveries were made by tomas
lindahl and that was in in the early 70s
that he made his discoveries then the
transformation in understanding how it
works holes in human cells that took
another 10 20 years before sort of that
come to I wouldn't say completion
because it still studied the others or
did their breakthroughs in in in the 80s
and middle of date is late late 80s
that's what wounded at the breakthroughs
and but also them was also son ER and
mudras continued and transfer the
knowledge from the e.coli bacteria into
the mammalian system and then we are in
late 90s and in early 2000 even so thank
you yes please over there you're getting
a microphone
and just a short question why did it
take so long for you to give them this
price yeah that's a question that's of
course it's difficult to answer but each
year we have a number we have close to
400 nominations so it's if we price
cannot win every year I guess that's the
simplest answer it is also fair to say
that this story has unraveled step by
step and and the enormous importance has
become clear more and more during more
recent years as tomas lindahl is a
member of the academy could he have been
here today voting as well or I mean how
common is it that you give a prize to a
member of the Academy oh that's very
rare indeed has it happened before I
think so I the last prize in chemistry
was in 1948 to Ornette azaleas and I
wasn't even a member then he was
probably a member but I don't know how
it was hell tomas lindahl has not
participated at all in this process not
attended any of the meetings or
contributed in written form to any of
the evaluations of course more questions
yes we have one over there hello yeah
Matilda from Nordic Chinese times and
wondering a little bit from the Chinese
site just about not about this price at
all but about the nomination process
because there's a lot of Chinese people
like often wondering how this process is
going like how its proceeding and how
you send out information are you
actually sending out information to a
lot of universities around the world
about how to nominate people for this
price yes this is exactly what happens
so a lot of universities and also
individual scientists around the world
get a letter where they are asked to
nominate
okay is it also in all the different
languages and all the different
universities the letter is in English
okay by this sent to universities all
over the world and we pay special
attention also to make sure that we
include all parts of the world alright
thank you and we invite nominations from
individual scientists at universities we
don't necessarily ask for nominations by
the president of the university or the
Minister for science or anything let its
nominations by the scientists themselves
by the international scientific
community and we as professors new
goreleans I said we really work hard to
make sure that universities all over the
world are invited to nominate it could
be scientists in China one University
the picking one year charging high the
next universities in South and North
America and Africa throughout Asia and
Europe and Australia we don't cover and
talk this yet but once there is a
research university and authorities will
make sure they get the chance to
nominate two more questions if not then
there will be opportunities for
interviews with Nobel Committee members
for those who you have requested it but
this session is about to close we hope
to see you back on Monday for the
announcement of the Prize in Economic
Sciences thank you very much for your
interests and your attendance Thanks bye
[Music]
yeah yeah okay
we're comma we comment
No
troz Gustafson you're a member of Nobel
Committee for chemistry can you tell us
some words about this year's price the
price this year is about the cellular
systems that preserve the unity
information so it turns out that the DNA
molecule which includes the NSTIC
information in our cells that that
molecule is frequently damaged and it
might also be mutated and that can be
caused by both by external agents like
sunlight the UV radiation in sunlight by
smoking different agents in smoking but
it can also be internal sources like
reactions with water
which happens at the quite high
frequency actually we also get mutations
in the DNA when we replicate the DNA so
every time a cell is divided we need to
create two new copies of the DNA and
together these different sort of sources
or mutations and damage can create a
real problem for for our genomes and
preservation of the Unitec material and
what these free price low rates this
year have have done is that they have
investigated and described in chemical
detail important processes repair
pathways that can correct these mistakes
when they arise and it's both in there
are three different areas of DNA repair
that we've been focusing on one is this
basics issue repaired to take care of
all mutations or chemical damages I
should say two bases many of them
spontaneous or paralytic we also have
the mismatched pair system which takes
care of the rare mistakes that DNA
polymerase leaves behind when it
replicates the DNA and then we have the
nucleotide excision repair system which
takes care of for example you've induced
damage and and other types of for
example agencies smoking so that's what
this year's price is about was recent
discovery they made that the history
fair system so the existence of some
sort of DNA repair is something that
goes back a very long time and probably
the first first identification repair
system was discovery of an activity
called food to liars in bacteria which
could overcome UV induced damages but at
that time the mechanisms for how that
happened was not known at all this was
back in the forties and then in in the
early in the middle of the fifties when
when they saw it in extracts
actually transforming that to
phenomenons in in sort of cells and in
in in in extracts it's something that
all this free stuff lorries have done
they have taken so the preliminary
observations and made it into sort of
real chemistry and when it comes to the
food Elias which I didn't talk about
during this price price president press
conference it's actually assistant yahoo
has cloned the gene identify the protein
and described a mechanism for this
really important and Sun the reason I
didn't talk about this prepare today was
that this is actually something that's
found only in bacteria we don't have
this type of repair in ourselves but all
these are the three types are repair
they were first identified in simple
cells and then it turned out that this
knowledge was applicable also to our
higher human cells and that we have very
similar systems that take care of damage
to to our DNA
but the repair system is not enough we
still have diseases cost but by the
damage of DNA how big part of the
diseases is you as it's their origin in
this process one can say that Dean
imitations how to put this I mean if you
think about cancer I would say that all
forms of cancers start with a mutation
or a DNA damage that's how they start we
know so I mean that's how important is
this and if you don't have repair system
that take care of the damages as they as
they occur the frequency of cancer for
example becomes much much higher and
there are diseases where you have where
you have disturbed
repair mechanisms they don't work as
they should they are in terms there
themself mutated and that then you get
very high levels of cancer
one example is said their mapping into
so this is characterized very carefully
by by an excellent American scientist
his name is John cleaver and he found
all these different genes that cause our
Dharma pigmentosa and then it turns out
that all these genes actually were all
most of them actually encode components
of the nucleotide excision repair system
in human cells and these the people or
the patients suffering from this disease
they cannot repair you've induced damage
as they should and they get extremely
sensitive to to sunlight they need to
stay stay inside and when they go inside
when they are subjected to UV light they
develop different types of tumors and
they often die from m'ling melanoma or
or this type of skin tumors so that
that's that's the importance of it but
then of course a certain length
limitations is also something that's
probably needed so even if the cells try
to lower the levels as much as possible
of course you don't want a frozen genome
because Dorian evolution requires that
or at least some mutations that take
place and that we can utilize for
selection yes even if I think that the
focus in luring in in luring mutation
rates but I mean they can't have
positive effects are there any concrete
drugs or treatments treatments that have
developed from this research I can say
that we understand now how some
treatments work so for instance
radiation it's something that it's you
know widely used in the treatment of
different types of cancers and what one
thing one important retort radiation
does is that it induces breaks in DNA so
it breaks down the DNA in cancer cells
and breaking down the DNA means that we
overwhelmed the repair system the repair
assist there are so many DNA damages
that it cannot cope and then the the
cells might choose to be into program
cell death or apoptosis and so suddenly
we understand at least one way that that
is that radiation works there are also
new drugs being developed where one
tries to to utilize the effect the fact
that many cancer cells have a defect
repair system order to begin with so by
by inhibiting repair actually in the
cancer cells you might get something
that we call synthetic lethality and
that would sort of specifically kill the
cancer cells this is a very interesting
concept has been currently developed and
I think that there are a number of
different pharmaceutical industries that
are looking into this and I think there
are one or two drugs that are actually
already available that builds on this
concept it's very active and if you
think about DNA damage I mean think
about all the things that we read about
cigarette smoke we read about avoiding
sort of sunlight or
think about catastrophes like that in
Fukushima with the nuclear sort with
radiation if the threat is to our DNA
it's our genomes that are being affected
and these are the machineries that
trying to fix it for us actually I
thought that Alfred Nobel was a chemist
chemistry was his field what do you
think he would say about this year's
prize I think it would be happy and
proud I am very happy I think that this
is a prize in the tradition from the
discovery of the DNA understanding how
did the DNA sort of read by
transcription and now understanding how
you actually preserve this genetic
information which is so important for
life thank you very much
you